one thing that strikes me is that even
for professional investors economists
forecasters it's really really really
hard to forecast and time a recession
correctly so I think that's something
all investors should really keep in mind
is that even some of the best Wall
Street strategists economists if you
keep hearing about a recession sure
maybe we'll fall into a recession in the
first half of this year but maybe we
won't you know no one got 2022 right so
I think it's important to take all of
these forecasts
um with a grain of salt because it's
really hard to time the market and kind
of position perfectly for these things
foreign
[Music]
to have on the podcast today leads
writer for the Wall Street Journal CNBC
correspondent award-winning journalist
gunjan Banerjee welcome goodjin
thank you for having me Andrew I'm
really excited excited too because I
have wanted to pick someone's Smart's
brain about the markets in the economy
of 2023 ever since the Year got started
which I guess isn't that long but I made
a series of predictions the beginning of
the year and one of them was that I
thought that there would be an economic
recession 2023 and I I based that on the
fact that I had a bunch of conversations
with various investors and CEOs and let
me say that their mood could best
described as lousy or something along
those lines and I put that into my
predictions in part because I wanted to
send a message to people it's like look
this might not be the year of mammoth
risk-taking
so what do you think of that and also
what kind of uh uh sources of
information do you get as someone who
works for both The Wall Street Journal
and CNBC thanks Andrew well I just want
to start by saying that you are not
alone when it comes to feeling or
thinking that we are going to enter a
recession in 2023
um and I feel like even in 2022 so many
people were were predicting a recession
um it just it kind of even became part
of a part of Pop Culture right you had
rapper cardi B weighing in uh saying
that she thought we were in a downturn
commenting on high inflation so it's
it's been all about
um when are we going to enter a
recession and Wall Street is expecting
one in 2023 like for the investors I've
been speaking with it's kind of the base
case like to a lot of people it's not if
it's when does it happen
um
to be honest I wonder if we're too
pessimistic because when I look at the
economic data uh you know the Friday
jobs report unemployment hit a 50-year
low like if you want a job
um it's it's still easier to find one
than it has been um at a lot of
different times over the past decade so
it makes you wonder like why are we so
pessimistic about the economy are people
too gloomy about the economy going into
2023
so so you talked about the scuttlebutt
you're getting from Wall Street
investors do folks talk to you both on
the record and off the Record do you
just have casual conversations and see
what's going on and they'll say hey
between you and me uh and and then
they'll download stuff to you
yeah I have I have a range of
conversations with investors right A lot
of these are on the record I'm quoting
them in my coverage and then I'm always
looking to chat with people off the
record on background uh just to get a
sense of where their heads at what
they're seeing out there in the market
you know when they're putting on trades
when they're investing and that's those
types of conversations are super helpful
I'm also looking at you know all this
economic data that comes out of what the
big banks are saying so there's there's
like a deluge of information out there
to kind of parse through on on any given
day fascinating uh and so you you kind
of choose what to share what to write
about and then other things you keep to
yourself until it
um it becomes story worthy so some of
the big stories in the markets over this
last few months really
um there's been a massive pullback in
the tech sector uh which had enjoyed
this kind of
um sense of both growth and froth and
safety I suppose it's like can't go
wrong if you just buy Amazon Apple
Netflix
Etc and then simultaneously you had this
crash in crypto where the space lost
trillions of dollars in value and
everyone is fascinated by the Sam
Beckman freed story it's like you know
like you can't get enough of it which I
get
um as someone who met Sam and know a lot
of people that know him
um so I I will confess to everyone here
I was someone who looked at all the
political donations Sam was making and
saying well I can't we get some of that
but I never actually succeeded
that's all I was among which now I guess
is like a pretty good look
but but you had this
implosion of crypto uh and then this
massive pullback in large cap tech
companies uh first did do you see any
spillover from crypto into uh the other
markets and second what do you make of
the relative collapse in valuation of
the big tech companies
so far a ton of spillover from crypto
into the stock market the bond market
and I think that was really interesting
because that was a fear I had heard
about quite a lot you know when I'd be
meeting with sources talking to them
they were like watch out for you know
when you see this big deleveraging you
see all the selling in the crypto market
watch out for how it ripples into the
stock market and the good news is it's
been relatively insulated interesting
that being said it may not be over yet
right we don't know where also crypto
from here right like it's still trading
near 20 000 well off the peak last year
um but there's people that think it's
going to zero there's people that think
hey this sell-off is actually just
beginning
um and it's interesting the tech bubble
keeps coming up in my conversations with
investors where
a lot of investors do see comparisons
with what's happened to Mega cap Tech
the Facebook's Netflix's Googles of the
world and um what happened when the.com
bubble burst in 2000 and what they've
been saying is hey that took several
years to play out right we're we've seen
one year go by the fangs have really
been dethroned um
in the market but you know what is next
do these companies keep selling off and
I think you do have a class of investors
that's saying the sell-off is just
starting and it's it's not over just yet
in some of the more speculative corners
of the market and even in the safer big
technology stocks I think it's really
it's hard to overstate how important
these companies are to our society and
and also investors where
you know one of my cousins uh the past
few years he got into investing and he
bought the Fang stocks he bought
Facebook at Apple and Netflix Google and
he felt really rich on the way up right
like he kind of laughed at me for my
index fund Investments and was like I
I'm I'm up like 70 I'm up this much and
he sold out of those stocks now and he's
moving to index funds now and I think
you're seeing that in several parts of
the market well let's talk about that a
little bit because one of the things I
want to do is provide some kind of
practical actionable uh guidance for
folks so
um you've done what most smart people
say to do which by the way I also say to
do um which is don't try and outsmart
everyone uh don't pick individual stocks
and think you're you're a genius uh that
you're better off just taking a broad
swath of uh stocks in a bucket through
an index fund
um I personally would recommend an ETF
uh you know like you could take an ETF
for the S P 500 100 and ETF for dividend
yielding stocks like dvy and then just
set it and forget it
and and then you might have a smart ass
cousin who's like hahaha like like you
know look at me uh making out
um but that only works in in One
Direction and I'm someone who thinks
that my my family uses how like Amazon
Prime in our household
um and I can think that Amazon is
integral to the day-to-day lives of a
lot of Americans and still may be
overvalued because if you just look at
the numbers you're like oh you know uh
like you know like x00 billion uh or in
some cases even over a trillion like you
know does that compute so it's it sounds
like you're also someone who uh has
adopted index funds in terms of their
personal uh financial planning
yeah and look I can't give investment
advice and I don't do that in my
writings for for the journal
um and I have certain limitations as a
reporter and to prevent conflicts of
interest I'm in in Pretty State index
funds right my retirement accounts I
will say that
um during the past two years in 2020 and
2021 people just had an insatiable
appetite for risk right they wanted the
riskiest stocks they wanted to trade
options so seriously they they were like
how can I find the next Amazon right
that's going to loom large over our
society how can I you know get into the
next Tesla the net the next Netflix so
they they want to trade on margin you
know that means you're borrowing to kind
of magnify your bets they wanted to
trade options they wanted to take trade
risky ETFs and I think in my
conversations with individual investors
this year um some of them had said hey
look I realized that I wasn't going to
be successful doing that anymore it was
a lot easier to trade when the market
was only going in One Direction up so
they said now I'm kind of just passively
investing um dollar cost averaging into
these index funds rather than making
making beam stock bets or these YOLO
YOLO trades in the market yeah and I
think that's what you won your award for
uh you might have won multiple Awards
but it was like reporting on Meme stocks
thank you yes one advantage to the
setting and forget it is uh it just
gives you peace of mind I mean what
happened to me I'll share is that uh
before I decided to run for president I
was like you know what I am going to
have zero bandwidth to think about any
of this [ __ ] so I'm just going to
do like the most plain vanilla stuff in
the universe and just like ignore it for
the next couple of years and it
definitely uh
gives you peace of mind where you know
you like you're not thinking about this
stuff at all
um now that kind of runs contrary to uh
the market watching culture and I have a
relative who you know is essentially day
trading while I was ignoring everything
so you know I mean there's a a spectrum
one of the things I recently
rediscovered uh is that there are now
high yield savings accounts that are
paying you know three and a half three
point seven five percent I was like wow
I've not seen those in years like like
we're back to that now yeah and you know
I was talking to an executive of a big
brokerage and he was telling me instead
of you know some of those single stock
bets what he's seeing interest in is is
people looking to you know what's the
yield on this money market fund what's
the yield on the savings account how can
I get yield and the money sitting there
in the safest possible thing and and
that's a big shift from what we saw and
you know to your point about set it and
forget it I think one thing that isn't
talked about enough is just the
emotional roller coaster sure that it is
for a lot of day Traders you know they
they have sleepless nights wondering
about their Robin Hood accounts you know
seeing it fall further after they
thought they were buying the dip and
that's one thing I heard about a lot
last year were people initially when
they saw stocks fall they were like oh
I'm buying I'm buying Nvidia on a
discount I'm buying Tesla on a discount
guess what happens after that it keeps
falling which is really really painful
when you're kind of all in the market so
I've heard about a lot of Anguish out
there over the past few years those are
two very important ideas number one
there are psychic costs uh to being so
focused on the market and number two
there's an aphorism
um try not to catch a falling knife
where you see something dropping and
you're like ooh discount and then uh you
know it can it's going down
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I've always been into sleep as one of
the best ways you can invest in your own
health and the way you can sleep better
is by getting a new mattress from Helix
sleep just take a personalized quiz at
helixsleep.com and they will send you a
mattress out of their 14 individual
mattress types that will give you the
sleep of your life and if you don't like
it you can return it risk-free for up to
a hundred nights I know it's bananas
Helix has been awarded the number one
mattress pick by GQ wired and my kids
who seek it out it's their favorite
mattress in the house and there are some
mattresses that frankly I spent more
money on than the Helix mattress Helix
is offering up to 350 off that's a
bigger amount than ever all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com slash
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
you also mentioned Tesla stock which has
been one of the you know biggest stories
it's had a very rough period And I think
that
in addition to a recent report where
they uh you know fell short of delivery
expectations but the the big story is
that uh Elon musk's attention has been
on Twitter and also that there have been
a bunch of people very publicly saying
you know what I don't want to buy a
Tesla now because like I'm I'm not as
enamored with this uh version of elon's
persona and Tesla had I think a very
clean futuristic uh green energy Vibe
where people felt like they were
extraordinarily Progressive uh by buying
a Tesla
um and I I think that's been a bigger
part of the stock story than really even
like the the more recent delivery
numbers yeah and you know I think the
thing that looms large over all of that
is that the 10-year treasury yield which
is like The Benchmark for so many things
across Global markets is now trading
closer to 3.54 yeah um
exactly right so the math that every
single investor does is you know what
can I get from the risk-free rate versus
putting my money into something like
Tesla or the broader stock market and
that calculation has completely changed
this year
I will say Tesla was really the poster
child for some of the euphoria that swap
markets in 2020 2021 people were trading
options on Tesla borrowing on margin to
trade Tesla and what we're seeing right
now is just one of like the fastest
drops in market value of a major U.S
corporation in history so it's really
really mind-boggling to watch
um how you know elon's attention has
shifted how that Community has involved
um one really interesting thing is that
individual investors have actually been
sticking with Tesla they are still
buying Tesla in huge amounts so they
have a lot of conviction in the stock
and I think it tells you that you know
elon's fan base is still there Tesla's
fan base is still there but also some of
these habits that we learned that
investors learned like my cousin over
the past decade of buying tech stocks
buying growth stocks you know those old
habits uh really die hard so good engine
we're talking about how it's not wise to
try and stock pick but you know who seem
to be excellent stock Pickers are
members of Congress
things that strikes me as common sense
is that lawmakers should just be
essentially uh forced to just buy index
funds and set it and forget it and then
when they leave office they can resume I
think most Americans would agree with
that what do you think yeah I mean it
certainly does seem like a big conflict
of interest and I'm surprised that they
they are able to do that
um just I'm going to plug some of the
journals excellent reporting on the
conflicts of interests and And Trades by
judges
um by by people who work at the
government as well as as well as those
in Congress because it's been really
eye-popping for me to see um that you
know people across the government can
kind of stock pick and stuff like that
you know I mean I I've been in some of
these rooms and I gotta tell you I can
see very easily how it would happen
where your legislator or very senior
official and you're just around all
these uh senior business people all the
time and they're your friends they're
your supporters and then if they say to
you like hey there's this thing going on
um and there's no rule against you
taking advantage of it
that that it'd be very very natural for
you to pull a trigger and feel smart
um and then everyone's trying to do you
favors anyway
um so it's setting people up to
unfortunately trade on information that
the Public's never going to have it
whether
who trade on such information whether
it's judges or people in the government
or or you know people in Congress do
they manage to outperform the S P 500
like I think yeah they do they do you
think they do oh yeah because I've seen
the numbers about the proportion of
members of Congress who are millionaires
which by the way now is like well over
50 percent of them are millionaires but
but that was not true when they all
showed up and so you think about it and
say wait a minute you're getting paid
174 000 a year which is a fine salary
but you have to maintain a couple
residences how did you enter a
non-millionaire and then emerge a
millionaire like 8 10 12 years later
it's because their stock market returns
are phenomenal like if the if someone
but I would love to see the Wall Street
Journal do a story on this to the extent
that the information is publicly
available because I'm very confident
that they would uh be whipping all of us
I just think it's just so so hard to
beat the index and to be passive
investment so that's why that's why I
bring it up and that goes back to the
risks that we were talking about oh I
I'm I'm very confident that members of
Congress are doing what the rest of us
cannot wait we just beat Index market
returns on the regular
we all want to get a little bit more for
our money nowadays and one way to do
that is use expressvpn to access content
you can't get in the US let's say you're
a Netflix subscriber all it takes is one
tap of a button to change your locations
you can control which country Netflix
switches to I've used this when I wanted
to watch Vikings which is a great show
by the way because it wasn't available
in the US but it was in another country
there are now over 90 countries to
choose from and expressvpn works on
multiple streaming devices and services
not just Netflix so stop paying full
price for streaming services and only
getting access to a fraction of their
content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com Yang don't forget to use
my links you can get three extra months
of expressvpn free that's expr ESS
vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang Netflix and other
streaming service is anywhere in the
world
[Music]
I was just in Asia
and China's gone from zero covid to like
everything's open
um in Breakneck speed I have family
members who are in Asia who frankly got
covered pretty much immediately because
like I mean they're fine they're fine
they're young they're you know like uh
um uh young parents and in our age I
mean it was stressful but their their
symptoms were fine one of the questions
uh I I've wondered about is how much of
the world's supply chain
um is going to be impacted by China's
opening up so there was some optimism
when they first announced they're
opening up the markets went up because
they're like oh good you know like no
more of the zero covet stuff but then
people started actually getting covid
and uh showing up in in hospitals and
the like
um the estimates of death uh in China
they start at something like one and a
half million and go up from there China
is going to report numbers differently
in a way that frankly is going to end up
under accounting uh the the impact in a
very significant way but for those folks
who are looking at the markets are you
seeing or hearing that the supply chain
is going to have problems because of uh
China's reopening what's so far I think
you're right is that we've seen a lot of
the optimism in the market reflected
right we've seen International stocks
actually outperform to start the year
over the past 30 Days by an incredibly
wide margin after really lagging behind
the us for a while and and the surge in
China stocks certainly plays a role
it's tough to say right now and I think
this is really one of the biggest wild
cards for investors right right now a
lot of investors are hoping that supply
chain issues are kind of a thing of the
past you're seeing a lot of measures
show that supply chain pressures you
know there aren't as many ships at the
Los Angeles Port waiting to unload
anymore I feel like a lot of investors
I'm hearing from are saying we're hoping
those issues have peaked we're hoping
inflation has peaked and that the CPI
figures will show that inflation is
declining that being said that's the one
big wild card for markets and it's one
that no one has gotten right the FED did
not get it right in 2022 most investors
did not get it right in 2022. you know
not one person I was talking to at the
start of last year was saying they
thought we'd end the year with interest
rates at the highest level since 2007
and inflation as high as we ended the
year so
I'm reluctant to even you know forecast
or say what could happen there because I
I just don't think anyone has gotten it
right and it's it's kind of the biggest
risk to markets right now that inflation
doesn't go down and that these supply
chain pressures don't stay down
yeah if China can't
manufacture and ship things uh things
like iPhones or all of the things that
are built there that inflation will end
up staying persistently high and then
the the FED to your point
um isn't going to look I mean they're
already talking about not lowering rates
this year the question is whether rates
go higher so one of the reasons why I am
negative on both the market and the
economy is because my friends uh who are
fund managers say that uh the high
interest rates uh will have an impact
that has not truly been felt just yet
and you referenced it earlier with the
fact that now uh treasuries are paying
three and a half percent
um so you have
risk-free returns that are all of a
sudden more appealing which will depress
stock market valuations because they're
looking up saying wait a minute like you
know you have to compensate me for for
taking this risk where before you felt
like they didn't have to necessarily
um well and my friend said that there
are a significant number of actors in
The Market that were essentially Reliant
upon low interest rates and cheap money
uh to have their businesses make sense
and and now if they uh you know are
paying higher borrowing costs like
businesses don't make sense so uh so
that's going to be an ongoing problem uh
the similar Dynamic is in the real
estate market where mortgage rates are
now six seven eight percent uh which is
much higher than they were gosh what
were they were like less than half that
not that long ago
um and so if you're looking at buying a
home now all of a sudden your barn costs
are much higher but the prices haven't
changed the sellers are not like oh
interest rates are higher I guess I'll
uh you know bring the price down and so
the prices are staying relatively fixed
so what my friend in real estate is
saying is that just deals aren't
happening you just have like these the
buyer and the seller looking across this
uh this Gap at each other and so the
volume keeps falling so how does that
play out I mean in my mind logically
prices have to come down
um because uh you know at some point if
you need to sell you need to sell
um and and there are different people
who are in in that position Edition
um so those are some of the the massive
adjustments I think need to be made is
that a lot of companies need to try and
adjust to a high interest higher
interest rate environment which some of
them won't be able to do and then the
real estate market has to to price
correct totally and that goes back to
what we were talking about in terms of
tech right where take meta platforms
right now they are hoping to make these
huge investments in their business these
huge capex Investments and I think years
ago investors would have said sure spent
spend a ton of money on that we think
yeah to be I mean that's that's been a
disaster huge huge flop um and part of
it is just that these huge companies
these Tech and growth companies just
don't have the leeway that they did from
investors
um for a long time it's like your
Geniuses do whatever we'll just Pile in
money's No Object exactly that was fine
when when interest rates were zero and
for a lot of the past decade but now
that they're not anymore you know the
cost of capital total has soared it's
it's more expensive to borrow
the valuation gain has changed so a lot
of investors are saying
you know we don't think you're worth
what you were worth a year ago so that
changes the game for these Tech
Executives you talk about meta and the
metaverse
um so uh one I I'm seeing these TV
commercials advertising meta and the
Oculus headset and virtual reality
trying to get people to buy it for the
holidays or whatnot
um and I thought to myself
wow I don't think this is gonna work
like I don't think that tons of people
are gonna buy this thing and
folks who log into the metaverse have
been pretty consistently disappointed uh
where that they've logged off and said
that this this is a wreck So Meta has
lost uh something like 600 billion in
market cap or whatnot uh they're they're
laying folks off I mean that that's
certainly another one of the biggest
stories and uh it it's to me uh a sign
of like a single decision-making point
where Mark Zuckerberg has you know
controlling uh ownership of meta and so
he's like hey guys metaverse Future
Let's Go hundreds of billions of dollars
and and no one's around to be like hey
Mark uh you know no one wants to do this
yeah it's very um it's very 2010s I
guess where these tech companies just
became more and more powerful and they
could invest in these moonshot projects
and investors said sure here take our
money and they became trillion dollar
companies and um we've seen that
completely fall flat over the past year
and I think it'll be fascinating to see
how that plays out in 2023 you know do
the market values of these tech
companies shrink even more
um and you know going back to what you
were saying about interest rates and
mortgages a lot of that depends on what
the FED does you know yeah all the
evaluations let's do yeah for sure yeah
it depends on um how much higher they
raise interest rates and that will
impact you know borrowing costs housing
affordability as well as valuations of
companies like apple and Tesla and
Amazon and
um we just have there's just so much
uncertainty about this thing right now
that impacts every corner of financial
markets and one really interesting
Dynamic is that there's almost this like
game of chicken between Wall Street and
the FED right now because the FED is
saying we're going to raise interest
rates to the five percent range and
we're going to keep them there until the
end of 2023. the market various like
interest rate derivatives markets and
swaps markets showed that show that
investors are betting that they're going
to start cutting rates way before that
even though even though they've said we
are not cutting rates
they've said that so many times and
still you have the market pricing in we
don't think the FED is going to do that
so it's it's really a fascinating
Dynamic and um yeah I think one of the
biggest questions for markets and the
economy in 2023 is who's right is it
Wall Street is it the fed and how high
do they raise interest rates and you
know as we as we kind of discussed at
the top of the call do their interest
rate increases tip the economy into a
recession which is everyone's fear right
now so is Wall Street pricing in no
increases or is it pricing in uh the
interest rate actually getting cut so
they are pricing in increases for the
next few months before the FED starts
cutting toward the end of the year and
that like reflects some of those
recession fears that we were talking
about because why would the FED cut
rates they would cut rates because their
policies are Rippling through the market
right people are are unable to afford
maybe homes or they pull back on
spending because things get um things
get so expensive and maybe that pushes
us into a downturn and then they would
have to cut rates so it's a very nuanced
perspective but that is indeed what the
street is pricing in right now
foreign
well that that that's that's fascinating
I mean my friends tell like who are in
the business said something to me around
it's going to get worse before it gets
better and that they they think that the
opportunities are going to come
um after q1 and Q2 uh they think Q3 Q4
which it sounds like it's somewhat
consistent with what you're saying that
the market is is projecting so uh the
new Congress got off to Iraqi start
where Republicans couldn't figure out uh
you know their speaker situation
um it got
resolved with Kevin McCarthy in the 15th
try uh I didn't notice any Market
response uh where you know I feel like
DC's dysfunction
um is getting worse and a lot of
Americans are looking up saying well
like this crew doesn't seem to have its
act together uh and the legislative
environment is really really cloudy
given that you have to get Republican
House Majority on board with something
that a Democratic Senate majority is on
border with and like what does that
overlap look like you know minimal at
Best in my mind
um is there a sense that legislative
dysfunction is already kind of priced in
where people just are shrugging and
saying sure like DC is not going to do
anything for the next two years you know
it's kind of sad but I feel like in in
what I hear from investors see from
analysts and stuff I do think some level
of dysfunction is priced in but not a
whole lot of investors
um and and my phone calls lately have
been even bringing up let's go going on
in Washington I feel like the focus is
so unilaterally on the fed and what
they're going to do it's just okay
that's good to know we're just fed fed
fed it kind of is an inflation inflation
inflation
um because we've seen dysfunction in
Wall Street before right we haven't seen
interest rates as high before we haven't
seen inflation this high at least since
the 1970s so we're kind of we're in
Uncharted Territory there for even a lot
of investors who haven't lived through a
kind of a macro environment like this
whereas I feel like from time to time we
do see you know stalemates in Washington
to crop up well the the biggest
historical echo of this you'd have to go
back to the 70s when inflation was this
dire and uh one interview I had on the
podcast was with a guy named David
Rubinstein who founded Carlisle and he
worked in the Carter Administration uh
in the 70s when inflation was I think it
might have crept up to the high single
digits even double digits and then uh
Paul volcker the Fed chair at the time
had to raise interest rates to a point
where it caused a significant recession
uh even I think it was called
stagflation because you had negative
growth Earth and persistent inflation
and it got Reagan in uh four years later
like you know Jimmy Carter wasn't able
to get his way out and so David
Rubinstein joked with me on a podcast he
said well no one wants me back in
politics because last time I was there
you know like you had 10 inflation that
he was joking yeah because he's
obviously you know like now a very
successful investor and and the rest of
it but
um you're right we haven't seen anything
like this since then and that's uh gosh
I mean that's even before my memory uh
uh like I was born in the 70s so you
know I like you know as a four or five I
don't remember uh what's what's going on
um but you must talk to some gray beards
you remember that yeah I think the
stagflation scenario I do think some of
those fears about that worst case High
inflation low growth stagflation and
stagflationary environment I think those
have eased as we've seen inflation come
down a little bit
um but that is literally a disaster
situation right where that would mean
the FED would have to raise rates even
more
um but again it's it's all such a wild
card I'm not sure if you heard Jamie
dimon this week say the FED has said
they're going to raise rates to around
five percent I think it could maybe be
six percent you know what does that mean
for the stock market we really don't
know
um
I mean that would that would be uh you
know tectonic so I've spent some time
with Jamie dimon
um and a number of years ago he came out
and said that the American economy is
not working for the average American and
we should come up with like a Marshall
plan to rebuild the economy which I
appreciated
um from from Jamie
um he's been one of the more dour alarm
ringers uh recently and
uh Ray dalio was also the podcast and he
said something similar about the
American economy not working for the
average American if Jamie's right I mean
we'd be in for a very very rough go
because it would be uh you the only
reason interest rates would continue to
go up like that is if inflation just is
very very persistent and stubborn
um and you can plausibly say hey if you
have a supply chain shock because of
covet in China like that could happen
there there are different Wild Card
scenarios to your point though right now
more optimism is creeping in because
we've gotten a couple of good data
reports lately totally and but I do want
to I think you bring up a really
interesting point about is the American
economy working for for the average
American or for the average worker
and I think one of the most fascinating
Dynamics playing out right now is during
covid
the inequality was just on full display
right we saw the stock market soar to
new heights white-collar workers were
sitting at home on their laptops on zoom
and you had blue collar workers out
there braving covid right
um and it seemed very unfair and I think
inequality was really just on Stark
display at that time
during the recovery after that brief
reception that we saw in 2020 I do think
what we've been seeing in the jobs
figures and in some of the wages figures
is just unbelievable demand for for blue
collar workers and I think they have a
lot more leverage
um than they did you know even a few
years back and I think in the past
downturns they were they kind of faced
the brunt of the layoffs and you know we
had the journal recently reported is
that changing is that Dynamic evolving
because I think what we're seeing is
that you know these big tech companies
are laying off workers where there's
still so much demand for for some of
those blue-collar jobs so I think that's
that's a really important thing to watch
in the economy in 2023 is how does that
evolve
so you and I have been talking a lot
about the markets
um which people use as a proxy for the
economy but the
top 20 of Americans own 80 plus of stock
market wealth uh and the bottom
48 of Americans own zero stock market
wealth um so you have the market on one
hand and then you have the economy on
the other uh now of course what happens
in the market effects uh quote-unquote
the real economy because of uh people
going out and spending money and
optimism and a bunch of other things we
we said before that crypto hasn't really
affected the market even as the market
had a relative downturn the real economy
has stayed more or less intact
um what do you think about the Market's
relationship with quote-unquote the real
economy
um out there uh it are we seeing an
environment which you just suggested
which is that look the average American
can actually be on the upswing in terms
of wages and the rest of it even if the
markets don't fare well the thing I
would start with is that the stock
market is absolutely not the economy and
that has never been clear right during
covid businesses around the country
where shut down you know we were all
sitting at home and the stock market was
soaring and thanks to you know those big
tech companies that really Loom large
over the S P 500 Index and now
unemployment is super low wages have
been ticking higher the the one thing I
do want to say on the unemployment being
low the labor market has shrunk
um since since covid so there are a lot
of people that went home and they just
have stayed home uh the number I saw was
something like 2.6 million
um and eventually you would think that
they would have to come back into the
workforce though if you spend time out
of the workforce unfortunately sometimes
you kind of stay out of the workforce uh
that you know yeah you can atrophy in
various ways so you write the headline
unemployment number is uh like three and
three and a half percent it's like very
very low but the labor force
participation rate is staying also
stubbornly low and we're all trying
we're all hoping that more people
re-enter uh the the workforce but it
hasn't happened yet so so I think there
are some signs that it's happening and
we get the journal recently cited some
research from the St Louis fed and I
just this is so interesting I just want
to read it to you please yeah I love it
it showed that the St Louis fed
estimates that falling asset prices may
have led nearly 400 000 American workers
aged 51 and up to join the workforce to
rejoin the workforce
um between January and October from last
year so maybe there is an increasing
relationship right between the stock
market and the economy where I think so
many people saw their portfolios kind of
swell during the pandemic and maybe some
retirees who who would have stayed at
home decided to re-enter because stock
prices were falling and it'll be
interesting to see how that progresses
in 2023 because to your point yeah the
labor force participation rate people
are sitting on the sidelines do they
keep entering um because of what's going
on with the stock market gunjin that's a
very very dark
a snapshot because what you said was
essentially that there are you know uh
51 to 54 year olds you've seen their
savings decrease in their portfolio is
diminished and they were like oh no I
better get out of work like I thought I
might be able to
um uh sit back and retire I mean like
it's incredibly yeah that's not the spur
you want to get someone out there like
that that they're they feel like they're
going to be destitute
no and of course it's actually for
retirees
it was just a terrible terrible year
well I guess this data shows they
re-entered between January of October
last year yes and that was one of the
worst years on record for this
traditional 60 40 portfolio of 60 stocks
and 40 bonds so it was just an awful
year
um to to kind of decide to retire and
you're right it is very sad if they had
to re-enter although this data was for
people aged um 51 and up but also there
were like you know young young traders
who thought that they
you know were could trade stocks or
citizens yeah
I think we've all heard some of those
anecdotes so um you're right it is very
sad if you know would be retirees would
have to re-enter the workforce but I
guess my point is that these Rising
asset prices
um seem to have played some role in the
labor force participation rate that
that's fascinating and uh you know I
know people who are governors of the St
Louis Fed so you know I'm sure that they
they uh excited that you're quoting
their data they literally they're like
very proud of their data
yeah they have some of the best data
around
um it's true I I also do have a couple
of college savings accounts or
retirement accounts that resemble that
60 40 allocation where you know when I
made it for
um my child I was like sure and then I
haven't looked at in a long time and I
looked at it recently I was like wow
like that's lower you know like you look
at it so I can imagine unfortunately uh
Americans looking at their accounts like
snapping to attention saying like what
like this thing has gone down you know
15 18 20 22 or whatever it is and then
it changing their decision making yeah
and how does it impact you know your
spending in in the real economy yeah
your your job your job choices and all
of that um so you sound like one of
those people who only opens a retirement
account when it's going up and the stock
market is going up you know I I'm pretty
much a funny duddy so like the dollar
cost averaging the set in forget it the
just like look contribute that much and
and don't think about it that's been my
Mo over this last period of time when I
say period of time I mean it's been a
number of years now
so you know do I have a lot of friends
who are you know like doing much more
aggressive risky types of investing like
heck yes like I've got a lot I've got a
lot of them
um but I'm pretty boring in part because
okay like my energies have been focused
in this other direction uh and I just
did not want to have my bandwidth sucked
up by monitoring things yeah and things
have been so volatile so it it would
take a fair bit of monitoring so you
have uh bird's eye view the markets the
economy you have sources uh all over uh
Wall Street and Main Street I'm going to
give my kind of like basic message and
guidance which is one of the reasons I
wanted to have you in and then I'd like
you to sort of you know like project uh
out out as well
um I see this as a transition year and
probably something of a painful
transition year I personally think that
people should uh look for uh
conservative
bets and and risk-free returns I mean
again right now you probably have money
sitting in an in an account that pays
you less than half of one percent uh
because you know like I mean I do I'll
just speak for myself and then I looked
up and was like wait a minute there are
accounts now paying three and a half
percent like I should probably get on
that this would be like a very good year
to consolidate uh to maybe a bit more uh
conservative in your decision making and
to be in a position where things that do
have some pullbacks that you're not
losing sleep over it uh that's my
personal orientation for certainly
um the first half of this year I think
that some of these high interest savings
accounts are a good idea I think that
index funds are always a good idea uh
particularly those that pay dividends
which are a really great way to balance
out your returns and lower volatility
and you know I just want people to stay
safe out there uh you know like I think
I project an era of Entrepreneurship and
optimism and which I do and I do have I
mean it's genuine but I I also have a
sense as to the way that people can live
uh with peace of mind
um and prepare for the future in a way
that that's not going to leave them in
the Lurch you know it's funny that um
you brought these high-yield savings
accounts because it's almost like
inflation protected bonds became the New
Meme stocks over the past year with you
know the the US uh treasury just seeing
unprecedented activity there
I think and again I'm I'm not you know
here to give investment advice yeah or
anything like that but I do think that a
lot of the Shams that kind of cropped up
over the past few years have have
unraveled right with FTX
um spax not necessarily a sham but this
thing that you know seemed to Skyrocket
and you know just the things that kind
of seem too good to be true it turns out
they really were too good to be true and
it's really hard to get eye-popping
returns out there I think one thing that
strikes me is that even for professional
investors economists forecasters it's
really really really hard to forecast
and time a recession correctly so I
think that's something all investors
should really keep in mind is that even
some of the best Wall Street strategists
economists if you keep hearing about a
recession sure maybe we'll fall into a
recession in the first half of this year
but maybe we won't you know no one got
2022 right so I think it's important to
take all of these forecasts
um with a grain of salt because it's
really hard to time the market and kind
of position perfectly for these things I
I agree with that uh I I think that uh
economists have gotten something like
zero of the last 10 recession calls
right
um and uh you know what I said before is
like trying to outsmart everyone is uh
not a great approach I mean that's true
for any of these forecasts and calls too
you know you just want to do something
that you're you're you're comfortable
with and it really infuriates me when
political figures either talk up the
market or talk down the market or take
credit for the market because nine times
out of ten they had nothing to do with
it yeah I mean historically stocks have
gone up through through many
presidential and political Cycles right
and the economy the economy does seem to
have been on an upswing since covid but
the stock market isn't reflecting that
right now gunjin thank you for being a
voice of reason and Sanity and
perspective how can people keep up with
you and your work you you are on Twitter
um which is one way people can follow
you are there other things people can do
thank you for asking I am on Twitter I
tweet a decent amount about markets and
the economy at gunjin JS and I'm on
Instagram at gunjan SB well really I'm
going to be excited about watching uh
your commentary and progress
congratulations on
um a phenomenal start to your career I'm
going to guest art just because you know
you seem
you see
um relatively young and and the next
time there's like a massive implosion uh
or catastrophe or something like that
we'll have to have you back happy to
come back this has been so fun chatting
with you thank you Andrew thank you
gunjin